>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WELL, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION IS
ACCELERATING AND AT SOME POINT
POSSIBLY SOON WE WILL SEE
ROBERT MUELLER'S REPORT OR
PARTS OF IT.
IF IT'S NOT RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC PARTS OF IT WILL BE
LEAKED.
WE'LL HAVE THE INFORMATION.
BUT HOW SHOULD WE ASSESS IT?
ALAN DERSHOWITZ THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT THE QUESTION AND RETIRED
HARVARD LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSOR AND AUTHOR OF "THE
CASE AGAINST IMPEACHING TRUMP"
AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: ARE WE LIKELY TO
SEE THE REPORT IN WHOLE OR
PART AND WHAT SHOULD WE THINK
WHEN WE DO?
>> WE WILL SEE THE REPORT,
PROBABLY THE WHOLE REPORT
EVENTUALLY.
BUT WE SHOULD NEVER SEE IT
UNTIL WE ALSO SEE THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM
REBUTTAL.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT'S A
COMPLETELY ONE-SIDED
PRESENTATION.
REMEMBER IT'S LIKE AN
INDICTMENT.
EVEN THOUGH IT WON'T BE AN
IT'S ONE SIDED.
IT'S BASED ON THE TESTIMONY
ONLY THAT THE PROSECUTION
CAUGHT TO CALL.
EVERYBODY KNOWS INDICTMENT
CAN'T BE USED AS EVIDENCE OF
GUILTY AND IT DOESN'T
UNDERCULT PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENT.
IT'S JUST A CHARGING DOCUMENT.
THAT IS THE WAY WE SHOULD READ
THE REPORT ISSUED BY MUELLER.
THIS IS SIMPLY AN ACCUSATION.
WE MUST SEE THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE STORY BEFORE WE CAN COME
TO ANY CONCLUSION.
SOMEHOW PEOPLE THINK THAT IT
DESERVES MORE CREDIBILITY
BECAUSE IT'S A SPECIAL COUNSEL
REPORT.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS JUST
ANOTHER PROSECUTOR LOOKING AT
ONE SIDE OF THE CASE.
HE WILL PRESENT A ONE-SIDED
ACCOUNT WHICH WILL BE VERY
CRITICAL OF HIS SUBJECT.
>> Tucker: SO THE REPORT,
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT
THE REPORT HAS BALANCE IN IT
OR SHOWS BOTH SIDES OF ANY
QUESTION?
>> QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S A PROSECUTORIAL REPORT.
IT WON'T SHOW BALANCE.
ANYBODY THAT EXPECTS BALANCE,
FAIRNESS OR NUANCE IS LOOKING
AT THE WRONG KIND OF DOCUMENT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE BALANCE WHEN
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE STORY.
WHEN YOU HAVEN'T CALLED
WITNESSES WHO MIGHT BE
EXCULPATORY.
WHEN YOU HAVE ONLY TRIED TO
PUT TOGETHER A PROSECUTORIAL
CASE.
THAT IS WHY IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM BE
PERMITTED TO ISSUE THEIR OWN
REPORT AT THE SAME TIME THE
MUELLER REPORT IS ISSUED.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
SO PEOPLE WHO SAY WE NEED
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED AS
AN INFORMATIONAL EXERCISE WERE
LYING TO US.
LET ME ASK YOU A MORE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY, YEAH.
>> SO EVERY PERSON WHO YIELDS
POWER IN THE SOCIETY BY DESIGN
HAS SOME SORT OF OVERSIGHT.
WE CAN DEFEAT OUR ELECTION
REPRESENTATIVES -- ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES IN ELECTIONS
OR RECALL THE JUDGES.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL CANNOT BE
FIRED BECAUSE THAT ITSELF IS
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
IS THERE ANY OVERSIGHT OF ANY
KIND OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL?
>> FIRST OF ALL, FIRING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD NOT BE
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE, BECAUSE
IT WOULDN'T BE THE CRIME.
THE PRESIDENT WOULDN'T -- THE
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE AUTHORITY
TO DO IT BUT IT'S POLITICALLY
DAMAGING TO DO IT.
THERE IS TECHNICALLY OVERSIGHT
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE WAS RECUSED AND NOW WE HAVE
AN ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL.
REGULATION REQUIRES THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO MICROMANAGE THE
WORK OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE IS NOT LIKE ANY OTHER
U.S. ATTORNEY UNDER DIRECT
SUPERVISION.
THE ULTIMATE CONTROL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS WHETHER
TO RELEASE THE REPORT UNDER
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES TO RELEASE
THE REPORT, WHETHER TO REDACT
PART OF THE REPORT, WHETHER TO
REJECT PART OF THE REPORT AND
SEND IT BACK TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO SAY LOOK YOU DIDN'T
DO A GOOD ENOUGH JOB.
GO BACK TO DRAWING BOARD AND
DO IT AGAIN.
UNLIKE ANY OF THOSE THINGS
WILL OCCUR.
EXCEPT I THINK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD BE WISE TO
DEMAND THAT BEFORE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL REPORT IS RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC OR CONGRESS THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM BE
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
AND REPUT IT AND PROVIDE THEIR
OWN REPORT.
THEN THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND
THE CONGRESS CAN SEE BOTH
SIDES IN TANDEM AND MAKE AN
INTELLIGENT DECISION WHERE THE
RIGHT IS AND HOW TO BRING
NUANCE AND FIND THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH IS BEST ACHIEVED
THROUGHED ADVERSARIAL PROCESS
AND PRESENTING ALL SIDES OF AN
ISSUE.
NOT PRESENTING ONE SIDE OF AN
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE
PREMISE OF THIS SHOW, BY THE